Speaker 1: Let's hear from the most important
people to the David Pakman show the viewers
and the listeners.
We like to take calls via discord.
You can join the discord at David Pakman dot
com slash discord.
It's an incredible thing.
We are going to start calls today.
How about tristin from washington.
Tristin from washington.
Welcome to the David Pakman show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: This.
Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Oh, good heavens.
To Betsy on a racetrack.
Right.
Such an honor to start the show today.
Speaker 1: The honor is all mine, sir.
Speaker 4: Thank you so much.
So a couple of things.
One, I've called your show a few times before,
and one of the last time you called, I was
in Oregon.
I am now moved to the Seattle area and we
had discussed on a previous call a chocolate
babka.
And I am happy to report since I have moved
here, I've found three different Jewish delis
in the area and I'm very happy.
I hope that I can compare the two and get
back to you.
Have you been to Seattle?
Do you know about any of these places?
Speaker 1: No, I haven't.
But, you know, I follow very closely J. Kenji
Lopez Alt, who does now live in Seattle, and
he seems to post some great food spots in
Seattle.
The food scene seems to be quite lively there.
Speaker 4: Oh, it's.
It's very exquisite.
I, I really can't wait to try everything that
it has to offer.
It's.
It's going to be a great experience.
And I can't wait to give you my report once
I've experienced the culinary traditions of
Seattle.
Speaker 1: Now, let me ask you one thing.
The chocolate Bob.
Yeah.
That you've seen around there, they're not
putting chocolate chips on top, are they?
Speaker 4: Well, I.
So I just moved here.
I haven't gotten a chance to actually go down
there.
Like I said last time, the only bad guy I've
tried was the Trader Joe's.
And they do put chocolate chips on.
Speaker 1: They're actually very, very suspicious
about chocolate chips on top of the babka.
Okay, that's my advice.
But report back when you know more.
Speaker 4: I will definitely do so.
Can't wait to do it.
Next question.
Sure.
I have a bit of a quirky guy.
I have quirky beliefs and I've been I want
to take you back to the founding of our country.
Yeah.
222 years ago when judicial review was was
established by the Supreme Court.
Basically, they gave themselves that power.
And because the Supreme Court has been in
the news so much and I realize this is not
actually going to happen anytime soon, but
I just kind of wanted to get your opinion,
do you think?
That overturning the precedent of judicial
review would actually solve a lot of the problems
that the court has caused for us.
And following that, do you think what sort
of system, if you David Pakman where the founding
fathers of this country, what system for the
court do you think you would establish?
Speaker 1: You know, I don't.
On the second question, I don't know.
That's really more of a question for a legal
scholar.
I'm sure you'll find all sorts of random political
people who will weigh in, but I really would
leave that to legal scholars, that judicial
review.
What you're talking about with judicial review
is essentially review by the Supreme Court
of the constitutionality of legislative act.
So it's sort of a melding of what are legislative
acts carried out by the House and Senate and
the president, and then comparing and contrasting
that with the Constitution, the Constitution
Bill of Rights, and seeing whether it is coherent
with that.
And it is sort of like an ultimate final word
in a sense, on the decisions that are made
by our legislators.
And there are people who say, well, that's
really a check and a balance that's not actually
appropriate.
And it allows the Supreme Court to become
even political than than we already know it's
allowed to be.
I don't have a strong position as to whether
I would get rid of judicial review.
What I'm more interested in is I think that
there are reforms that can be made to the
Supreme Court, including term limits and creating
a pre-determined replacement schedule to take
out the politicization and strategy around
holding on for another year or not.
There are other things that I would like to
change about the Supreme Court, which I've
outlined in content on the show previously,
which for me would be lower hanging fruit
than the judicial review question is really
a bigger one, and I'd leave it to the constitutional
law scholars.
Speaker 4: Okay.
I completely understand.
And I and I agree with you on that.
The only reason that I bring it up is it seems
like, at least to me and the time that I've
spent on this earth was just very short.
It seems like we have sort of an ontological
problem in this country where we think that
like because something happened a long time
ago and it's been in place for a long time,
that somehow it's better for it.
Speaker 1: Well, that's conservatism in a
nutshell, you know?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it definitely is.
And, you know, I've been reading about the
French republics and the different, you know,
constitutional conventions that they've had
over the years since they founded their first
constitution.
And I just it just so refreshing to hear about
how they've done it and the maturity of that
country.
And I just wish we could do that here.
And so we wouldn't have to have conversations
like this where it's like, well, is one big
reform that's not going to happen Good.
Or is a small reform that also probably won't
happen.
Is that a good thing?
You know?
Speaker 1: No, I completely agree with you.
And I think one of the biggest problems in
even having many serious political conversations
in the United States is a huge contingent
that says that just because it's what was
done in the 18th century, we should, of course,
assume that it's the right way to do things
today.
You have to break through that before we can
seriously talk about a lot of different things.
But, Christine, I appreciate the call.
Very important elements questioned today.
Speaker 4: Always great to hear from you,
David.
Speaker 1: All right.
There is Christine from Washington with a
very powerful series of declarations.